liverpool in northwest england has
become the first city in britain to mass
test
all citizens for the coronavirus around
100 000 people have been tested there
since the scheme was rolled out nearly
two weeks ago
liverpool has among the highest death
rates in europe from the pandemic
the hope is that mass testing will help
to break the chain of transmission by
identifying asymptomatic carriers
dw's charlotte chelsea pill reports
this is being billed as the uk's latest
weapon in the fight against covid19
with the city of liverpool on the front
line they're piloting a city-wide
testing scheme
the first of its kind in the uk and a
massive pr campaign's underway to enlist
the half a million people living in
liverpool
the more people get tested the better
we can protect that great city and drive
the disease down let's start
the fight back against covet let's get
tested
let's do it together let's do it for
liverpool
local authorities have set up dozens of
testing sites across the city
and they've brought in the army to help
the logistics
considerations of this operation have
been significant
and we deployed 2 000 troops to the city
of liverpool within
three days across 45 sites liverpool
volunteered to try the mass testing
operation
after recording one of the highest
covered rates in europe
authorities hope that by testing as much
of the population as possible
they'll identify more asymptomatic cases
and break the chains of transmission
the scheme has tested over a hundred
thousand people since it started a week
and a half ago
but there's still a long way to go we
haven't been here we haven't had the
time but
we will it's it's a good idea though um
i've had mine
done and both me and my husband were
negative but
i think to get the whole population
tested
you'd be able to identify who's got it
particularly those who
have it and don't show any symptoms but
it's important it should be happening
everywhere not just liverpool
yeah i think i hope it works and it
takes off yeah
processing tests quickly is the key to a
scheme like this
asymptomatic volunteers myself included
are asked to do the swab themselves
you get the results on your phone within
an hour
these are the lateral flow device tests
that are being used at testing sites
like this one across liverpool
now a lot like a pregnancy test they can
determine results in 20 to 30 minutes
and the benefit is the results can be
processed right here at the testing site
instead of in a lab and that's why these
tests
are the backbone of liverpool's mass
testing scheme
there's some dispute about how many
positive cases are being missed
critics also fear that getting a
negative test could give people a false
sense of security
that results only valid until the moment
you leave the building
and are once again at risk of being
exposed but local councillor paul brandt
says this scheme was never designed to
be
a silver bullet we need to explain to
the public that this is
not a passport to misbehave
this is part of the jigsaw of wider
public protection
it'll be difficult to tell what direct
effects this scheme has on cutting
infections
it's happening while england is in
lockdown but paul brandt says every
asymptomatic case that's identified
is a step in the right direction as
we've identified through that program
527 people who
we now know were positive who had no
symptoms and would not previously have
known that they were symptomatic
and infectious and they now can take
steps to take themselves out of
circulation and protect
themselves and their family and their
friends originally planned to last two
weeks
there's pilots likely to be extended
with increasing public engagement
top of their priority list but it's a
blueprint for the uk's testing strategy
and the government's already announced
more mass testing schemes in dozens of
locations
across the country to italy in italy now
which is
struggling to cope with the second wave
of the coronavirus on tuesday
the country reported more than 700
deaths that's the highest daily death
toll since april
during the first wave six months ago
hospitals in italy were quickly
overwhelmed
and a record number of people died now
healthcare workers
are terrified as they may face the same
battle
again
another patient with covert 19 being
rushed to hospital in monza lombardy
this region was the epicenter of the
outbreak in spring
when italy's healthcare system was
overwhelmed
now once again lombardy is the hardest
hit
but the volunteer rescue workers say
this wave is different
this month we've seen a repeat of what
happened in march
the difference is that we've also seen
young people with covert 19.
in march it was mainly elderly people
now
we have young people too
to try to contain the spread of the
virus many regions have shut down
but healthcare authorities say a
nationwide lockdown might be necessary
soon
if the situation doesn't improve
in lombardy mass testing facilities are
now being set up
more than 30 drive-in testing centers
are being planned in the region
each able to test hundreds of people a
day
and authorities here say the measures
are helping
the reproduction number appears to be
sinking
but the number of people in intensive
care is still rising
and many hospitals remain understaffed
some 5 000 doctors are needed in italy
at the moment
another young patient is being picked up
the woman in her 40s needs
oxygen immediately for the volunteer
ambulance workers
she's part of a seemingly never-ending
stream
pushing them to the limit for more on
this i'm now joined by giacomo graceli
in
milan he's the coordinator of the
intensive care unit network in lombardy
the region
in italy that we've just seen in the
report and that's hardest hit by the
pandemic dr gracely
the world watched as lombardi's
hospitals were overwhelmed during the
first wave
what's the situation now
well the situation is i would say is
slightly better than
march and april so to give you some
numbers
we had a maximum number of 1500 patients
admitted
at the same time to the icu for kobe 19
our icu bed capacity before the crisis
was 750
we have now 910
copy 19 patients and we we did with the
restrictions that have been implemented
we hope that we will not
uh overcome 1100 which would be
important because the number of
non-coveted patients this time
is uh quite higher so
certainly the the system is under stress
um
we do not have problems with the uh
availability of personal protective
equipment
and technical stuff like ventilators as
we had uh
last time um so this is better of course
what is different now is that people
health care workers are
really how can i say tired and
so it's more it's it's very heavy to
work in the coveted unison
and it's it's probably more difficult to
open
new new beds but we're doing it and
and again we are granting uh to every
patient who needs an icu bed
and i see you bad so i think that we are
going we are doing a good job but again
certainly the the the system is under
stress
but like can i ask you excuse me for
interrupting you there what did you
learn i mean it's different this time
around but
did you learn something in the first
wave that you can apply now to do things
differently this time around
well of course we well first of all from
their
organizational point of view we
we know now where and how
to open new events
so we are repeating many of the things
of the strategies that we had
implemented
in march and april uh again we
we were not unprepared from the point of
view for example of personal protective
equipment
and of the training of the person so
now everyone is trained on the proper
use of ppe's
and an adequate number of pps are
available
uh and from the clinical point of view
we have learned
something on how to treat the patients
and so hopefully i i think that the
like mortality in icu would be lower
this time than in march and april
do you think the summer months were used
wisely to prepare
italy for a second wave
no i mean not not really but uh they
weren't uh
exactly has happened everywhere in the
world so i speak to my my colleagues
in other countries and they all complain
about the same things
it's very difficult to if preparedness
means
opening a huge number of new icu beds i
mean
not temporary icu beds but but real i
see you that's a stuffed
it's very very difficult to do it in in
few months of course
[Music]
maybe you know we we we are still in in
lucky lacking doctors and nurses but
again
it's not so easy to recruit new new new
personnel during the the summer
season what we really didn't do very
well
was that probably the information to the
people was quite misleading like that
there were experts or or so-called
experts
uh who you know went on tv on the
newspaper saying okay it's
everything is over so you can do
whatever you like
and and so people did not really follow
the rules and and again this is what
happened
everywhere in the world so this is the
reason why this second wave is so huge
again
so giacomo graceli uh we have to leave
it there thank you
very much for joining us here uh on dw
news
thank you very much thanks bye
now let's take a look at some of the
other developments in the pandemic
poland has reported a record
603 deaths related to the coronavirus
as its health service also struggles to
cope with a second wave
experts are urging japanese authorities
to step up preventative measures after
tokyo reported 493 new coronavirus
infections the biggest daily increase
seen so far
and the u.s food and drug administration
has approved the first covet 19 home
testing kit
for home use that provides results
within 30 minutes
for as much as it is strict austria's
lockdown is also ambitious it is
supposed to slow the spread of the virus
significantly
and be followed by a mass testing
program
the goal to test everyone all 8.8
million people
in the country so much of austria's
lockdown depends on
public cooperation and that is true
everywhere
when everyone is not on board the
consequences
are the tragic scenes now playing out in
the united states
the austrian prime minister has issued
one urgent request to his nation
don't meet anyone
vienna's commercial district was full of
people on monday night
locals want to shop before the lockdown
since only grocery stores and pharmacies
can remain open during the next three
weeks
home goods and electronics are
especially sought after right now
i'm looking for a camera for e-learning
for my son so that he can take part in
live online lessons
i'm looking for everything that i need i
don't know how long the lockdown will
last
supposedly until december 6.
apart from shops and restaurants schools
and daycare centers are also closed from
tuesday
but here in vienna many establishments
offer child care for kids with working
parents
or those who can't take part in online
classes at home
she was with me the whole time during
the first lockdown
sometimes i had to have a zoom
conference and she was sad the entire
time
she's an only child she doesn't have
anyone else because he is unseld
she had me man there are exceptions to
the current curfew
people who must work in person visit a
doctor or buy groceries may leave their
homes
going for walks and exercising outdoors
is permitted but only with social
distancing
and there might be more signs of life
outside than there was during the
springs lockdown because this time
playgrounds and parks are staying open
well correspondent steve shade joins me
now from the austrian capital vienna
good evening to you steve
this partial lockdown we know did not
work
now it's the lockdown on steroids you
could say when you look out your window
can you can you tell the difference uh i
certainly
can today things are very tranquil uh
when the lockdown came into effect
things did
shut right down um and the contrast to
yesterday
uh was amazing because uh the lockdown
was announced on saturday
so everybody got ready for monday and
stormed the stores there were lines out
the door
not everybody wearing face masks so it
immediately became apparent
why the lockdown was necessary
lockdowns work they're not popular but
it's
what it was required uh when people were
left to their own devices
the infection rates um were off the
charts
and we're still seeing the effects of
that nearly 6 000
infections just over the past 24 hours
intensive beds
well the intensive treatment centers in
hospitals
are in danger of being overrun i think
austria only has about 522 beds left
switzerland hit capacity today it needs
to be stopped
the government plans to also test the
entire population
when this lockdown is finished talk to
me a little bit about the logistics here
i mean this sounds like a job for the
military
um if austria were to follow the
slovakian
model it would indeed require the
military um
testing more than 8 million people would
be a monumental task
but chancellor sebastian courts is going
to convene a meeting of experts
tomorrow morning at the chancellery and
even ahead of that meeting what's now
coming out is that what is more likely
is that
some sort of targeted testing will be
pursued
what they did in slovakia was they used
these antigen
tests which are not very accurate
and they're not really meant to test
populations where you're going to have a
lot of people testing negative
it's good to prove that people were
positive but it doesn't accomplish
what you need to to accomplish to find
out where you have clusters and why they
built
the big mystery in austria is why
the infections started to increase so
rapidly in some areas
so this mass testing program
will be clarified after this big meeting
tomorrow
whether austria pursues a slovakian
model is
yet to be seen but probably not likely
okay correspondent steve shade with the
latest tonight from vienna steve as
always thank you
all right we're going to stay in austria
now i'd like to welcome virologist
norbert
novotny to the program dr novotny it's
good to have you
with us the the partial lockdown did not
bring down the number of new infections
in your medical opinion is this total
lockdown for the next
two and a half three weeks is that the
right solution
first of all good evening um while
these partial locked down for almost two
weeks now
uh at least it plot holds the new
infections
and we see some decline in you know the
last two days
so i'm pretty sure that these complete
lockdown this hard lockdown
during the upcoming 20 days
it should work as we saw in in in other
places like
israel or the netherlands belgium
uh czech republic so there are a number
of
other countries which successfully
the hard lockdown worked successfully
and as we heard it is absolutely
necessary
but i think we will manage
regarding also hospital capacities and
especially capacities in the icu
what's about after the lockdown we
understand that austria wants to test
the entire population for the virus do
you know maybe you could explain to us
will these tests be for the presence of
antibodies or will these tests be for
the actual presence of the virus
no i think the idea is uh in the last
few days of the lockdown
to test for virus in order to
quarantine those which are still
infected
in order to save you know the last two
weeks before christmas
for shopping etc and not to start again
with you know a lot of virus circulation
during that time
uh although i think probably will not be
the entire population
um as you also said before i more
think uh it will be targeted
to to some certain groups of people
uh for example teachers because what it
definitely will do
is um the lockdown is until 6th of
uh december and on the 7th they will
open
and especially also the schools will
open uh
including the the school for the
uh people aged 14 to
18. and testing the teachers will make
sense and some other groups
dr norbert novotny joining us tonight
from
austria doctor we appreciate your time
and your insights tonight thank you
most welcome bye-bye have a good night